Yeah. Cause we w it's funny to think about,
I would have three levels of women in my heroine. Why, what would they be?
It would be for rum. Yeah. Okay. Forearm. So meaning like, listen,
you're so hot. It's not even in my control. You're just for Rome. We Pat,
you know, when we pass the girl on the street or something, or if you are,
what your friends do, you pass, go on the street and she's so high.
He can't handle it. That is for Rome level. There's nothing you can do that.
It's beyond your control, too hot. She's she's more than a 10.
She's the hottest girl you've seen. It's just, it's painful. How she is.
You just ride their Instagram wall for wrong.
So any, any.
Hot women you see, you get to start. If you start to see for Rome,
you know what we mean? She's like, I'll right now. Right now. I I'll ride on,
you know, Rosario. Dawson's won't, you're just, you're [inaudible] for rubbish.
I can't do anything. I have to take you for wrong. You know, part Dawn,
my tearing pot tear sheets got to come with me, Marone for Rome. Okay.
What's the other next level of course is, um, is, uh,
what was the next level of Rome is number one Alzheimer's early onset,
early onset scares.
It sucks because I always thought I'm going to be one that goes down first,
but you're. It'll be fun to talk to you as a puppet though.
It'll be fun to just watch you just talk and just say to you.
Cause what's the middle. What's the middle ranking.
We've just talked about a wrong, right? Yeah.
I honestly go deep as the lowest go. Deepest. The lowest
lead.
[Inaudible].
Rome at the top. Number one, number two is clean out, clean out.
So what do we mean by clean? Explain that to the table. Make no mistake.
You have to clean that out. You got to clean it out by any means necessary.
You're so hot. You need to be cleaned out. Not that you were dirty,
but I just need to clean you out like a dog with a peanut butter.
That is a perfect description of clean.
Just got to put your tongue in there and clean it out in and out.
It's what it is. That's so that's how you're that level hot.
And then the third and final level is go deep is go deep.
And what we seek go deep. What we're really referring to is Randy Moss.
If we said go deep or Randy Moss, that just means, um, you know,
Randy Moss was obviously, if you guys don't know, is a hall of fame,
a wide receiver, um, that would, you know, go deep and you know, would go deep,
take your couch. It passes from quarterback to catch it.
You could make means you could catch it.
So that's what we're trying to say with that.
So as always forum for room clean out and go deep.
And if you see me in Chrissy and you hear any wide receivers name,
that means just somebody in the vicinity that could go, Dave,
I could go there and you have to find them. So, yeah, so that's,
so that's kind of the Rome that we would live in.
And we've talked about that and we've joked about that a lot, uh,
in our friendship. And when we started researching Nero, we were like, wow,
the roam that we create it as a joke is the roam that Nero created in real
life. That's how wild that's how wild Nero was.
He just lived anything. See, here's the thing. Okay.
You don't even have to call this episode. Nero's wild.
We could just call it Nero because he's wild. It's self-explanatory that?
It's a fun. Yeah. It's like eponymous. Good word. Yeah. Eponymous.
I was going to say redundant redundant as the Ridgewood way,
but eponymous is to yeah, yeah, it. Yeah.
Yeah.